啊，来，我们说一下电视剧的写法啊，就电视剧怎么写呢？我说过电视剧从电影。
算是从电影演变来的吧。
因为早期电视剧它虽然是服务那个广告，但是你也得讲故事嘛。
你得让人看点啥。
所以他就是从电影变化来。
但是这几年因为。
哎，播播播播放环境播放条件不一样了。电视剧你强度越来越大。
对好看也要求越来越高了。以前啊电视剧是。
服务广告的现在电视剧也服务观众了，正儿八经服务观众了，只服务观众，甚至甚至可以这么说，他只服务观众。
所以我们来看一下这电视剧咋写。
我说电视剧真的会出现。
多人物。
多事件。
多视角。
这个一点不吹牛逼了，是真的会出现的。
那他应该怎么弄呢？
他应该怎么弄呢？
就说。
那这这这个这个这不就乱了吗？这电视剧应该咋写了？
我来教大家一个方法。
做独创。
也不算我独创的吧，也借鉴了嘛。
我们是编剧啊。
所以关键字儿。
就是编。
就是编就是多人物多事件，多视角杂写。
就是用编制的方法。
编制的方法去。
用编织的思维。
去把你这些。
好几条人物弧线，多个事件，有的事件是串联，有的是并联。
把它。
呈现出来，把它安排在。
一部电视剧的呃剧本里。
怎么编织呢？
大家先记一个口诀。
这些口诀就是要记的。
好吧，这些口诀是我我给你们的口诀就是要记的，别的书上没有了。
叫。
整体。
编人物。
整体编人物。
三级。
编实劲儿。
大家记住这个口诀，整体编人物，单机编事件。
我们说一部电视剧它的总的一个单位是一部。
一部电视剧的时候你编人物，然后电视剧呈现方式因为要分级要分级。
单级的话边是角。
一般的电视剧我们说一集是45分钟，对吧？
这个是因为是早期的习惯留下来的。早期的时候，电视剧是一集45分钟。
因为。
因为胶卷是15分钟一盘。
胶片早期他们也是用胶片拍嘛，所以它必须是十五的倍数。
然后电视台呢就就选了45分钟，他们认为最合适。
是一级，然后后来。
因为排片要固定这个排片的位置嘛。
就形成漠式了。
所有的。
电视剧都45分钟一集。但是由于现在这个播出模式不一样了，现在电视剧多少分钟一集都有都可以。就是因为大家现在的剧都不。
不需要去瞄着电视台了嘛。
多少分钟的都有。
但是还是以级为单位的啊。
单辑编试件。
整体编人物。
大家记住这个口诀。
我来给大家讲一下具体怎么弄，擦出一块地方啊。
你必须找个地方，正儿八经把这个编织说一说。
好吧。
关键词是编。
是吧。
编织我们说整体。
你给我编人物。
啥意思呢？啥意思呢？假设啊。
因为要编嘛因为要编嘛，我们来我们就要做表了。
做表了。
所有的编剧在。
在在在在在搞创作的时候，都会治表。
都会自己做表的，这个没有什么奇怪的，大家一定要养成这个习惯，要做表啊。来，我们说整体假设这横轴是整体一部电视剧的。
整个的横州我们按吉打点。
我们就按几打点，对吧？比如说这是第一集。
这是第20集吧，一共20集。
20。
来自横轴。
然后在纵轴上给他列什么呢？
整体。
看人物。
人物啊我们说有ABCD。
一。
5个。
5个主要人物。
不会主要人。
A。
在第一集在整部戏中，比如说。
他的。
人物互线。
他经历了什么？
假设他是一个穷小子。
变成了一个。
富豪啊。
对吧那他他是第一集，比如说因为穷被欺负。
然后这这里呢开始脱摸。
犯罪。
这里呢。
那个得到了一定的惩罚。
啊啊，这里呢。
开始觉得哦犯罪不行，我用正路赚钱，然后呢呃一步一步。
赚到了一些，然后遭受一次打击，差点放弃，然后被逼帮助了一下，这个绝力又重新来过东山再起，最后成为富豪，这就是A的。
整个它的弧线。
然后B也有自己的弧线。
对吧当然有可能这儿断一下，因为他气份没有A重嘛。
在1到3级哎呀，然后多少级多少级它是什么弧线？B是什么弧线？就是从整体规划的时候，你整体你编织你的电视剧的时候。
是按照人物为单位。
编的。
明白这意思吗？
这个意思明白了吧？这就叫整体编人物。人物的弧线在20集当中，你是怎么给人家？
分配的。
以人物为单位ABCDE。
明白吗？
然后。
那你说我这个戏我还没人物呢，我我还不知道怎么规划人物呢，我教你一个方法。
我教你一个方法。
就说现在的电视剧啊，这几年的电视剧，因为这个电视剧的发展，我说了，这几年电视剧极大的发展快速的发展。这几年的电视剧已经非常明显的趋向于经典叙事。
啥叫经典叙事呢？其实就是我说的简单叙事。
简单叙是啥概念来着？单一人物单一事件，就说这个主角是明确的，他想干什么也是明确的。
以前有电视剧，这个主角想干什么是不明确的。
红楼梦，你说贾宝玉想干什么？
他不没想干什么。
对吧。
他没想干什么。
他没有什么明确的事儿。
以前是有这种电视剧的。
现在已经很少了，特别是美国、韩国这几年已经很少了，就主角是有明确的自己的动力的。
但是我们也要适应中国的环境啊，你说一个一个电视剧只有一个明确的主角。
也不太好。
我告诉大家一种方法怎么样解决这个问题啊，你给我设主角群。
就比如说ABC。
是一个主角群。
就在总体规划上啊。
假设。
ABC。
是一个主角群。
你在心里面知道他们仨是一个人。
然后呢，你先给他们三个设一个共同。
是一个共同的呃成长路径。比如说啊咱们就说刚才的那个。
穷到穷到富。
穷到富。
对吧。
那。
这个是。
一个很明确的一个行动线了吧。
很明确啊。
穷到富，比如说第一件事儿。
是创业。
那么AABC。
在这条线上是统一的。
在治疗现象是同。
但是你可以呈现三个不同的。
不同的人物，不同性格的人物。
但是在这件事情上是统一的ABC都要从穷到富，对吧？
然后你就开始一条线了嘛，一条线你就有了嘛，然后你就开始做分裂。
就是电视剧的惯用手法。
B在这个点。
退出了。
哎，B在这个点退出了。
对吧然后呢，B就自己走一条路径了，然后C在这个点加入B了。
然后可能到最后B和C成功了，A back。
或者是怎么样，这个你自己去设计。
明白这个意思吗？就是说先给你的主角群。
你先定一个主角群，我说D，你看啊这还有个DD没包进ABC里面D可能是ABC的。
比如说是个竞争者。
或者是个对手。
但是不耽误地的戏份其实也很多。
你只是在剧本创作的过程中。
你心里明白，你把它是设成对手的。
但是从观众的观感来说，他可能戏份比B重。
明白这个意思吗？他从电影的角度来讲，他是个对手。
就是你先把主角群的行动线给他做出来。
他们有一个共同的任务。
然后再对主角群做撕裂。
主角群做撕裂，我可以给大家一个小的一个技巧，就是主线。
相声。
副线。
相克。
这就好做了。比如说他们的主线是创业，创业的话，他们三个。
各有神通。
他家境比较好，二代有背景，有资源。他呢。
特别呃能吃苦，特别聪明，对吧？他是智慧担当，他呢。
特别忠诚，他是呃他是他们俩的呃等于是催化剂软化剂。他呢就老师忠厚，叫我干什么，我干什么。
那他们在这条线上是统一的。
做思裂特简单来，你是个女孩跟AB产生。
这个这个感情，那等于浮现是爱情。
我们说腹线相克。
主线相生就他们合在一块是对主线好的。
但是辅线对辅线不好。
明白这个意思吧？就很简单的就可以做出来。
这种这种。
主角群你就这么去设定，主角群一定要设定共共同目标。
这个一定要记住啊，主角群你去设定共同目标。
ABC假设有三个主角，他们是有共同目标的。
得是经典叙事，得有明确目标。
他们三个人有一件事要办。
这个事儿当然不是说非得是啊今天我们去偷个自行车，是那种那么具体的事儿。比如说三个人要出人头地。
那也是个事儿。
然后但是他们的辅线对他们这个主线是有冲击，有撕裂的。
比如说腹泻。
第一特别忠厚，特别忠诚。他发现。
这个他被背叛了。
明白这个意思吗？这是这就撕裂主线呀。
就这么去设定。
哎，不好理解不好理解，我给大家举个例子好不好？
我们说这几年有个非常牛逼的美剧，叫绝命毒师。
绝命毒师这几年应该是巅峰之作了。
老白跟小粉两个男主。
等于是男主A和B。
他们俩共同的主线是什么？
制毒。
贩毒。
他们俩共同的主线是吃毒贩毒，一个是高中化学老师，发现自己得了癌症，命不久矣，破罐子破摔，因为很穷没钱，所以他觉得我有技术，然后我又得了癌症了，我就要我就要做毒品卖掉。他呢高中时候是他的学生，呃，本来就是个小毒贩。
那既然我老师跟我合作，然后又特别会做出来的病毒也特别好。然后呢，他们俩人合作。
主先非常明确，制毒贩毒在这个毒品呃黑帮林厉的毒品界混出。
也不叫混出一番名堂啊，就是扎下根儿就可以了。他俩开始的目标就A和B的呃共同目标。
然后这是主线。
主线。
两个人相生啊，合作相生。
辅线那就是来A。
的家庭问题。
A自己的有个家庭问题啊。
对吧。
他的家庭。
他他连接应该是这么叫啊，他连接。
是个警察。
缉毒警察。
连夜是个缉督警察，等于来C，假设是那个C是个基督警察。
给给他带来很多家庭问题。
要抓了。
对吧然后这个鼻呢，它有什么问题啊？他早期最大的问题是吸毒。
他吸毒他坏习惯，他不自律，然后经常会惹事。
也就是说他俩各自的。
线呐。
都都要撕裂这个主线。
一会儿他埋怨他。
一会儿他埋演他。
就他俩个各自的浮线都能撕裂这个主线。
所以你看啊主线。
是这件事情是观众的着力点酌情点。
他俩能不能制成烤的毒品能不能卖出去？就观众其实一直在关心这个事儿，但是他们俩各自的。
浮现。
都他妈的。
耽误这个事儿啊都耽误耽误这个事儿。
然后再去设其他的角色是BDE。
全部服务这个主线，要么是阻力，要么是推力，对吧？他们的俩人的御用律师就是推力。
他们俩各自的家庭就都是阻力。
他们俩这个他的一些朋友，狐朋狗友，开始是推力。
后来掉链子变成阻力。
所有的事情都是附着在。
主角群的主线上。
所以我说你这种整体把人物排出来。
一定要弄你搞明白谁是你的主角群。
哪些是你的主角权？当然还可以就是真正的。
传统叙事就是说就一个当然可以。但是一般来说，国内电视剧啊现在已经不做一个了。
看冒险。
太冒险，因为电视剧还。
毕竟还有一些。
以前电视剧的影子，你设一个单一主角的话，真的是有点冒险。
万一那观众就不喜欢他的脸呢。
所以你还得给他仨俩。
让这仨两办同一个事儿。
而且电视剧有一个什么，我没说完啊，我说整体。
ABCD比如说四个人物。
你这个横轴上。
再给我写一样东西，这个东西一定要给我写上去。
一定要给我写上。
叫人物关系。
就说A。
A的。
呃，发展路径B的发展路径，A和B共同的。
事业路径这些都是在。
在你的这张表上，你要规划的。然后C和D因为是配角，可能在这儿有点事儿，在这有点事儿，在这儿有点事儿。然后D一呢，在这儿有点事儿，在这儿有点事儿。
然后你一定要规划一个轴，叫人物关系。
叫人物关系。人物关系是什么意思呢？人物关系就是。
你的主角群的。
角励就是你主角群，你分出来的这几个人。
他们的关系的上下期。
你一定要单拉一条。
这样的话便于你整体规划你。
你整个剧的。
这个这个这个结构和节奏。
就是这么去规划你的整体人物的，就是整体上编人物。
第1集到第20集。
来你主角群假设是A跟BA和B有一条什么样的共同的？
行动线，然后A和A和B各自的人物弧线是什么？
然后其他角色。
在每在这个。
整个聚集。
中的剧情的分布。
他们的小成长又是什么？
然后最后单拉一条人物关系。
因为你到会最后你会发现人物关系非常重要。
人关系非常重要。
这个人物关系特指主角群的人物关系啊AB我们说绝命毒师里面就老白跟小黑呃，小粉小粉，老白跟小粉是拥有共同。
目标的。
主角群，所以他俩的人物关系是要单拉出来的。你去看他俩的人物关系永远是在起伏。
和好破裂和好破裂和好破裂。这个人物关系并不止比如说B跟C的关系或者B跟D的关系。因为这个小粉后来又谈恋爱，跟一个女的呃谈恋爱，然后那个女的不是也对他们的呃事业也造成冲击了吗？但是那个人的人物关系是不列在这里的。
那个就是他的自己的人物弧件就可以了。这个人物关系专职你的主角群的人物关系，你一定要做的，否则你这样写完了之后，你会发现你的主角。
群没有。
反复拉锯，这是绝对不行的。在一个电视剧里面，你的主角群一定要反复拉锯。
反复拉锯。
我们说你我给你举个例子啊。
我不知道你们看没看过一个剧，翻拍过好多次叫流星花园。
我说流星花园为什么？
只有就说道明寺跟。
朱渝民那个角色是叫花德类吗？
道明寺跟华泽类。
还是主角。
就他虽然是叫F44个人。
但是。
那个西门和美座啊。
他俩没有这个，你懂我意思吧？
就他俩永远是合适了。
是A和B在和好反目，和好反目和好反目。
明白这个意思吗？
他没有人物关系拉锯。
就导致了他俩他们四个人虽然一直在同时出现，但另外两个人存存在感。
就变低了很多，我不知道你们看的哪个版本啊，我是熬夜通宵。因为这戏热播的时候，我在读大学，我是熬夜通宵在网吧里看的，边看边哭啊，哎有酸菜啊，这当时激发了所有直男的少女心，你知道吧？这个这部这部剧。
他只有A和B有人物关系的纠葛。所以他真正的主角其实就是道平斯跟华泽蕾，没有另外俩。
他这他他就是欠这个，你知道吗？欠这个。
所以我提醒这是我自己总结出来的方法，我分享给大家啊，就是你。
整体你拉人物的时候，你一定给我单拉一个人物关系的曲线，单列一条ABCD都拉完了，再给我单列一个A跟B的人物关系的起伏。纸牌屋纸牌屋。我们说那个凯文史派西跟他老呃剧中的老婆就是。
那男女主角。
双线并进吧，他们俩各自有各自的事业呀，那个那个线特别干净啊，它一直是双线并进，线特别干净，对吧？
线特别干净。然后。
讲一会儿他讲一会儿他讲一会他，那是什么驱动那个戏一直往再往前前进呢？
就他两个人种关系。
那两个人就像一对。
真的是一对狼一样，你知道吧？一对一只公狼，一只母狼，一会儿他占优势，一会儿他占优势。他上去的时候他就下来，他上去的时候，他就下来。所以他俩这种关系一直是分分合合，此起彼伏。
但是他俩是有共同目标的。
就是在这个美国国会。
要往上爬爬到顶端。
两个人一起爬到顶端。
是有共同目标的。
一定要记住这个人物关系这一块。
好啊。
这就是我说的这个这个这个。
整体上你去给编人物。
然后你看啊，假如说这个AA它它在整体上。
他的事件是怎么排布呢？
他整体这个人弧线它是怎么排布呢？
就他的这个。
这条线它怎么还有？
其实也是按照我们说的时序列排。
就你上来先要介绍他的。
他的开场吧。
然后后来又有有他的激励吧。
这个老白第1集就发现自己得癌症了。
得癌症了。
然后又去跟他。
在他那个联金那里看到那些贩毒的人怎么这么多现金啊，他说啊这抓了一个小毒贩，哎呀，60万美金就刺激他呀，激励事件呀。
对吧，然后这这个到后面呃呃该危机的时候危机该转折的时候转折。
高潮的时候，高潮可以解决是不是。
他其实他的线啊。
也是按照。
序列来了，但是这个序列呢是会重复的。
是会重复的，它不是完整的电影序列。
那有时候呢。
激地事件连击好几下。
对不对？在电视剧里面编人辑好几下，然后转折转折再转再转再转。
是是有这个形态在的，但是它总体上。
所以我说为什么说电视剧的写法啊是是电影的一种变化？
可灵活运用就在这里。
你在每个人的他的故事的设计上的时候，他有大的方向。
上的借鉴。
但是也有变化。
明白这意思吗？你们先去体会一下啊，就是把人物。
还在。
整个比如说20级你面这张表里，然后单加一条人物关系的。
横轴。
就把它塞进去。
塞进去。
然后我们说电视剧毕竟它是。
它是以级为单位的那我们再再来看一下单级。
我们说单级。
编事件。
对吧我们说单级边事件来，假设这是这一集。
对吧。
那。
这一集发生了两件事儿，事件一。
和。
事件2。
一般一集啊，我们说中国的电视剧一般一集在2到3条线。
一般是三条线。
或者两条。
两条半也可以不到底嘛？来，假设是两条线，两条都都到底。
就是以事件。那么这事件是哪来的呢？
来，假设这是第二集。
假设这是第二级，你就从这里取，那这是第二级嘛。
对吧。
第二集A经历了一个激励。
那你先去找一个激励事件。
然后AGB这里。
然后你发现D在第二集有个出场。
那你看哦D可以放在事件一里面，把D的出场做进去。
然后。
第二级美元B。
B有一个我们说叫比如说它叫这个。
呃，在第二级面，B面临的是选择，那就另外一条另外一条故事线上是B的选择，对吧？B做选择。然后C呢C是几比，C反一是几励。
所以做C的几励。
然后。
你还想在比如说第二集里面，你还想做AB相遇。
对吧然后你在这两条线当中再做1个AB相遇。
等于是单级。我跟你说，以事件为纵轴，就是你把事件找到，比如说事件一是A开车出去。
撞到了底。
A酒驾撞了D。
然后。
跟地吵架的时候被B碰到。
然后逃逸。
你就找到一件事情，把你。
表一里面你要完成的这些任务。
装进去要完成A的激励，D的出场。
B的选择。
C的机励。
第二集吗？
就把这些事件。
呃，用事件把你要完成的任务。
都放进去。
都放进。
所以说来我们就在第二集里面选这条横轴上每个人。
需要做的事情。
然后把它。
以事件的方式结合进去。
以事件的方式，事件一事件2。
事件方式把它结合进去。
我们说那你这个这个每个人的这条线要做的非常。
对应每一集都要有内容的。
就是说A的整个整个A的这条线。
我们说在比如说是二十级里面。
那他可能比如说经历过4次阻力。
我说电电视剧他。
它是连续的，它可以有充分的蝙幅篇幅叙事呀，对吧？然后你说他在这里经历一个激励事件，他走向这个方向，他在这里可以再来他妈一次呃激励，他往另外一个方向走。